viewing the Flintstones through adult
eyes reveals a complex world with a lot
of darker problematic moments you
wouldn't notice them if you're a kid but
if you're a grown-up you yabba-dabba-doo
while the Flintstones is clearly a riff
on the groundbreaking sitcom The
Honeymooners it does make a few notable
changes the Flintstones is a bit more of
an equal opportunity offender when it
comes to domestic abuse Ralph Kramden
threatened to beat his wife so often
that his verbal promise of violence
became a TV catchphrase audiences never
actually saw Ralph get physical with his
wife but viewers of The Flintstones
saw it worked the other way around Fred
often threatened Wilma but that's where
it stopped
however when Fred did something Wilma
didn't like which was often she'd clock
him on the head drop heavy objects on
his feet fling him across the room who
knows what else
of course Fred wasn't the easiest
caveman to live with he had serious
anger management issues he constantly
twisted the truth and his views and the
role of women in society really did
belong in the Stone Age for a show that
took place millions of years ago The
Flintstones is surprisingly progressive
about a number of issues in the 1960s it
was revolutionary that the series was
open about how Barney and Betty Rubble
couldn't naturally conceive a child like
The Flintstones and how upset they were
about it it was a major TV event in
February 1963 when Wilma gave birth to
pebbles and afterwards the rubbles spent
an inordinate amount of time hanging out
with the new arrival they just want a
baby so bad as a last resort they make a
wish on a falling star
the next morning their wish has
apparently been granted and they find a
baby boy at the doorstep a
supernaturally strong orphan named
bamm-bamm however the couple still have
a long way to go before they could call
bamm-bamm their own adult viewers will
certainly feel some empathy as the
rebels jump through legal hoops to adopt
the little powerhouse and her only
granted custody at the last minute the
whole ordeal mentally drains Barney to
the point where he wants to take his own
life
luckily Fred shows up just in time to
save the day and BAM Bam's new daddy The
Flintstones wouldn't be the Flintstones
without animals birds and other
creatures performing all kinds of
household and mechanical tasks the
modern Stone Age family seems to have an
animal for every job a mastodon instead
of a shower a monkey bird tag-team
inside a record player
a swordfish for a kitchen knife and an
artistic bird that functions as a
prehistoric Polaroid camera just to name
a few you have to wonder what these
animals actually think of Fred guys a
pig and it's all your debt to me can
opener it doesn't seem like the animals
on the Flintstones are getting paid or
have any freedom whatsoever
in other words the humans of the
Flintstones have enslaved animals
forcing all creatures great and small
into being
suburban well this is cruel some animals
have it worse than others Birds tails
are constantly being yanked a pelican
serves as a trashcan meaning people
force-feed it garbage and possibly worst
of all a variety of poor creatures are
forced to sacrifice their entire lives
for construction and mining I've had
just about enough for these lazy excuse
it us is slave labor like most sitcoms
of the 1960s
the Flintstones was not serialized each
episode completely stood on its own with
Fred Wilma Barney and Betty getting into
some kind of hairy situation and
resolving it by the end of the episode
kids can accept this they can enjoy
shows on a surface level adults may want
to know more about developments in the
Flintstones universe such as what
happens after the events in the episode
dino and juliet in this comic version of
Romeo and Juliet Fred Flintstone and a
new neighbor get into a heated dispute
instead of the warring factions teenage
offspring falling in love their pet
dinosaurs do Dino Falls instantly
head-over-heels for Juliet the cute new
sauropod in town don't beat the bush
they know Jenna long as lovers are wants
to do dino and juliet steal away for
some privacy which results in the birth
of more than a dozen babies never again
on the Flintstones a Juliet or her
children with Vito scene
apparently he's an absentee father and
the love of and leave them tight after a
few years on the air sitcoms tend to
bring in a new character to breathe
fresh life into the series homeless teen
Luke showed up on growing pains cousin
Oliver appeared on The Brady Bunch
and the Simpsons mocked the entire
concept with a random character named
Roy adding a new character is often a
desperate attempt to boost low ratings
yeah yeah has the hang in everybody
morning right the Flintstones
pioneered this move back in 1965 with
the arrival of a tiny smug alien named
the Great Gazoo the little green et had
been sent through space and time to
prehistoric earth as punishment for
making a doomsday device on his home
planet Gazoo has clearly seen his share
of dark places
get off me mama Wow have you been
Fred and Barney discover him and rather
than report him to the government they
befriend him although Gazoo
mainly seems to call them dum-dums and
magically disappear whenever fred is
talking to him which gives the
impression that fred has mental issues
or maybe the Great Gazoo isn't real at
all and Fred and Barney have been
ingesting some unknown substances with
mysterious side effects yes
The Flintstones is a cartoon and it
passed strict Network standards in the
conservative early 1960s but somehow it
managed to sneak in the occasional dirty
joke for the adults in the room in one
episode Fred and Barney are watching TV
when they lose reception Fred asks if
everything is in working order and
Barney immediately hits Fred with a
comeback that would make most parents
blush in front of their kids how's your
Aunt Emma it would also seem they had
adult films way back in the Stone Age
well Fred's getting a check-up a doctor
holds up Fred's x-ray prompting
Flintstone to joke how about a doc
Flintstone and an x-rated picture while
these man cave jokes were right up Fred
and Barney's alley we can't help but
wonder how Wilma and Betty would react
[Music]
fern check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stuff coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]